let's see if we can write 12-point 0.98
as a mixed number so the first thing you
might want to realize here is that this
is the exact same thing as 12 plus 0.98
and this simplifies it because then we
just have to write it as 12 and some
fraction that's the same thing as 0.98
so if we can write 0.98 as a fraction
then we could we're essentially we're
almost done so let's see if we can do
that
so this 9 right over here is in the
tenths place I'll just write it like
that tenths place and this right over
here is in the hundredths place it's in
the hundreds place so you could view
0.98 two different ways you could view
it as 9/10 9/10 that's this part right
over here 9/10 plus plus 8 hundredths
plus 8 hundredths and if you want to
find a common denominator that would be
the same thing as 90 over 100 plus 8
over 100 plus 8 over 100 which is equal
to 98 over 100 equal to 98 over 100 and
so 9 0.98 is 98 hundreds and another way
you could have said that is look this
space right over here is in the hundreds
place and so this is 98 hundredths or
9800 so you could have skipped this
right over here
so if we just wanted to write it as a
mixed number we could just write it as
1212 and instead of 0.98 12 and 98
hundredths now we have introduced this
to lowest terms yet so let's see if we
can simplify this 98 is divisible by 2
and so is 100 so let's divide both of
them by 2 they have that common factor
so we're going to divide both of them by
2 and so this is the same thing as 12
and 98 divided by 2 is 49 100 divided by
2 is 50 and I think that's about as far
as we can do 49s factors it's divisible
by 7 but 50 isn't so we've put it in
lowest terms so 12 point 9 8 can be
written as a mixed number 12 and 49 50
it's